thinking of moving to another country in
the European Union did you know that
your rights to a pension are protected
take Johan he is German working in his
home country for ten years now he's
decided to follow his passion for skiing
and got a job in Austria so what happens
to his pension rights his pension
contributions remain in Germany they
don't get transferred or reimbursed any
contributions he makes in Austria or
likewise remain in Austria remember each
country you live and work in will keep
their own insurance records two years
later
Johan moves to France he settles down
there and starts a family on reaching
retirement age Johan will make his claim
in the country where he is living in
this case in France the French
authorities will liaise with the German
and Austrian institutions informing them
of yo.hannes pension claim Johan
receives a decision from each national
institutions and finally a document
summarizing the pension decisions made
by all the countries involved
remember when you reach pensionable age
every country where you have been
insured will pay you a separate pension
be aware that the conditions for
entitlement such as the pensionable age
and the amounts paid may differ from one
country to another johan reaches the
pensionable age in france at 62 and in
austria at 65 years old but won't
receive his German pension until he
reaches the German pensionable age of 67
but what happens if you don't comply
with the country specific conditions for
entitlement
according to Austrian law johan is not
entitled to a pension because he doesn't
fulfill the minimum requirement of 10
years of contributions
fortunately yo.hannes rights are
protected by EU social coordination
rules that oblige countries to include
periods worked in any EU country plus
Iceland Liechtenstein Norway and
Switzerland
in yo.hannes case Austrian institutions
will acknowledge his contribution
periods in France and Germany and pay
him an amount proportional for the two
years he worked in Austria
so whenever Johan decides to retire he
will be entitled to receive his pension
without losing any of his contributions
Social Security coordination enables you
to move around Europe and not lose out
on your Social Security rides
[Music]